i just wanna have a really good show
tonight
uh
so i gotta open with a strong joke i
know that much
so i thought uh
it's tough i mean i thought i'd open by
telling you that i just got back from
afghanistan where i was entertaining the
troops uh but
okay thank you but i was performing for
the taliban so
not gonna open with that um what i
thought my friends always say well john
just open with your funniest joke well
my funniest joke happens to be extremely
racist so
i think i'll close with it but
the opener
i know i think it's beautiful that we
have a black president of the united
states and relax this is not my closer
um i think it's great uh what's adorable
you know considering this country's
history the fact that there's a black
president is just beautiful uh what's
adorable
sure yeah what's adorable is that my
little nephew came up to me the other
day and said uncle john will there ever
be a white president in my lifetime
that's cute right
but how do you explain to a
four-year-old billy look you have
leukemia
[Applause]
or or as he calls it ukima
yeah yeah he he's also stupid now uh
it's a risky joke i know i uh
i did that joke on a show once and a
lady came up to me afterwards and said
hey great set i loved your jokes oh
thank you so that happened
uh you know
you gotta you gotta be careful with the
ladies you gotta be slick like i know
even if you suspect it you're never
supposed to ask a woman if she is
pregnant
so what i do is i say hey looks like
someone's put on some weight
you know let her tell you if she's
pregnant
don't ruin the surprise
be a gentleman
a friend of mine came up to me the other
day do you have friends like that where
they just come up to you
hi okay what
and uh he said hey dude if i can get
tickets to metal fest do you want to go
and i said no i don't like metal and he
said you don't like metal
[Music]
you don't like metal
like by him acting out the song that was
going to convince me to love the music
like you're not a wizard you can't act
something out and convince people it's
good you never see that you never see
you don't like beer
you don't like beer
you know or you never see
you don't like fishing
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
hey steve
how are you
not bad
no i knew you're up at the lake i saw
your boat
also i fell asleep in the sun yesterday
i think your kids came by they drew
another penis on my chest
yeah it looks like they traced it
[Applause]
oh yeah no my wife is fine
although my wife's starting to sound
like a laser gun
a laser gun
yeah whenever i'm like can i go the guys
can i sleep in can i have a beer she's
like
[Applause]
what did you just say about my wife
no no no you don't talk to her that way
all right we've been through
you son of a [ __ ]
that is my wife you want to do this
let's do it right now
you don't like fishing
you know what i mean okay thanks
everyone thank you very much